yeah welcome to this rapid game against
mahwah mahwah from Great Britain we are
going to play a benoni here and whatever
you can say about him is playing very
quickly let's see hmm ok i'm playing
with Bishop d3 and h3 the some very
solid set up check and I'm checking with
the e porn and he's blitzing and
blitzing and blitzing this is not a
bullet game buddy yeah of course this is
a fairly normal looking position so he
probably has some experience with this
going to play a form preventing could be
five ideas okay so it's a typical kind
of benoni well why does enjoying slide
space advantage okay what am I doing
here many many ideas Queen d2 Bishop f4
yeah maybe Queen d2 I think it belongs
there I don't know what is black doing
rook p 8 a-6 p 5 maybe no he's putting
the night to before okay it's normally
not considered to be very promising but
we're going to see what happens
then I yes to misplace pieces before in
a six but it's not like he's losing
immediately just that those two pieces
are simply badly placed on before i nee
six doing simply nothing but okay let's
see Quinn to discern ok so be sure black
Bishop f4 here or yeah let's think about
this for a moment yeah maybe Bishop f4
intended night to be five attacking the
weaknesses if he then has to take with
the bishop on b5 I'm I'm really
satisfied with things okay is going down
okay we want to keep this Bishop and I
can play g-form soonish getting the
night away them and 94 is also an
additional idea now that he has moved
the night to h5
that's always know it now it starts to
think the moment where he already has
totally committed to to a bed set up but
ok let's see um night b5 is definitely a
move my GF is also moved but this Bishop
h6 which is not really that convenient
so maybe start with 95 that looks good
going to maybe provoke him to take am
him yes night on before has exactly 0
squares ok trying to do something about
that mmm I'm going to take them
yeah probably let's see yeah I would
really love to play 95 two is six but he
has bishop age six another idea is rook
to e6 just opening up the Diagon all
right actually interesting rook takes
pawn takes Queen take this 95 as well
for 25 check that's that's actually
quite nice okay rookie 6 is a quite
annoying move then as d 6 is just
hanging ok so our cheeks and 95 let's
check 95
maji five looks good but yes Bishop age
6 yeah okay I can check your sex land
everything else feels I'll take you six
any other move basically I'm playing
Queen d5 and win he almost has to play
that
but Bishop age 69 is six Bishop d2 ads
not too clear he has to play that Bishop
h6 or am i overlooking a tactical
refutation and it's always possible a
knight is 650 to look to you one rupee
ate something like that maybe and maybe
not quite sure what he is thinking of
because bishop age 60 is the only move
yeah so what now move like rookie one as
answered by Bishop takes 25
and I wonder is there something nice
here so I don't don't see something
super convincing 9650 to break in td6
sir does this kind of thing that is
definitely better for white but it's not
devastating some way to do that
look T 1 maybe look D 1 well not sure
how convincing that is
my bishop on be oneness in general not
bad but it's not doing much at this
particular moment this also that's not
working and kind of tricky
okay week I'm taking him keeping things
simple root give one there is ruki aid I
wonder if I should go on a pod gvoice
actually a move very much if he cheeks
not sure k i'm going to take him rook e8
yeah i was thinking wookie 897 looks
wacky to trade off the night on a six
but I'm having a ready-made target there
on b6 really not sure how he covers this
then g4 was also an idea but I can still
play that I believe
the big idea of g-force to activate my
be one Bishop at the moment the bishop
is just looking at at five kind of
asking asking me who care what I am what
am I going to do here so g4 is probably
making some sense
yeah maybe still ruki a droopy 8 97 97
Bishop c7 rookie 6 it's probably not so
bad rook to e1 now it is it is bad I
mean he simply has the more exploitable
weaknesses and night on age 5 and so on
it's nothing nothing really great about
about black situation I'm not sure what
you should do what the the best is night
before for example i'm going to play g4
definitely
hmm yeah it's not much fun
yeah certainly did not exploit this to
the fullest somehow but it is it is nice
for white it's not much fun to play this
position I came what is it that you
should do can't it not even didn't
consider this one very seriously but it
doesn't look bad I came doing here right
and don't have many alternatives and
okay it's not really the most convenient
way ever to cover this pawn but I see
the point ok G for fighting for activity
for this Bishop here if he takes my
bishop gets access access to e form ok
so just recapturing I guess on this
should be for immediately Bishop before
this rook c8 and now that's not really
helping much so just recapture and now
g5 I guess why f3 I'd like f3 is a very
mmm-hmm not sure three is a bit more
solid but g5 I don't know having a shot
at 85 really getting the bishop in the
game more quickly
yeah okay well it is nice it really is
maybe beef is B 5 a mafia probably not
can play Bishop t6 maybe not trading so
much yeah taking on a 5 checking on b5
is also not bad I don't want to trade
that much
no next move I mean I don't know Bishop
before Bishop b6 will be the cover I
guess off 35 I'm not really threatening
the pond well I am I am I thought Bishop
takes rook c8 I can retreat because Roxy
for this Bishop a 2 with the skewer is
no great move I think that he has my
ideas g5 Bishop before still maybe I
should have played g5 anyway yeah okay
instead of f3 I mean okay so what am I
not able to take I probably am able to
take
hmm okay so what is the grand idea here
that probably isn't one so we'll just
Bishop back I can't repeat we see
threatening something I can just play
rook see one right and supporting in the
sea porn
maybe Bishop f2 and then c5 next Bishop
e3 should be three rookie to now can we
can play that
gather look on the second drangus
put up in an annoyance ear really it's
that way to play this yeah okay maybe
check it first maybe I should have
played g5 still in for Bishop e-form not
totally clear him Bishop f4 i'm playing
funny-looking move Roxy too but I think
it's good he has to retreat the rock
then and then I get in Bishop a to NC 5
check and this looks pretty well
coordinated and the rook trade is just
over I guess yeah well that looks fine
it looks fine or am i overlooking stuff
now i'm not sure it looks quite okay so
look here right
yeah it looks kind of strange but the
bishop is coming to a two with tempo and
that's worth something okay you have to
retreat anyway probably to e7 trying to
block on the on a dark square ok and
that's the only kind of possible
justification for the trade trying to
get to a reduced material end game that
might offer some drawing chances okie
dokie trying to check yeah I wasn't sure
about this so going to avoid I can take
now
why not sure not sure this is going to
be should be a draw thing capture ah not
sure but ok it's not not necessary
really to get to this again and I g3 hmm
ok I can play King III but I don't want
to trade him that was a stupid move
there was a stupid move check
no yes it was that was stupid allowing
this trade
hmm no not good
yeah let's see is this a draw is this a
win we're going to see soon let's get
this pawn going now I mean it's a very
it's just draw with without the pawns
then without the F&G porn I mean then
you can just block eight on a light
square but not sure with those pawns
maybe I can actually run up to f7 or
whatever getting getting to the pawn um
so c6 yeah it's difficult to want to do
without this let's see it's very
difficult to get somewhere here c 17d
seven should be five
at the moment she cannot approach the
porn so i can probably regroup a little
bit on king d 5 i'm promoting so maybe i
should go over to g form now that's
that's it's a good idea actually and
then try try from them
it's not easy for me not so easy could
have gone to III by the way it's a bit
quicker not sure why I went to d3 but
it's it's not not a matter of tempe i
think i can really just go this to do
this walk to g4 very often use simply
routinely um use them the light squares
in this end game because the bishop is
on a dark square yeah what is he doing
it's not that he has so many moves I
mean he can probably stay but should be
seven know what it disconnected or
something no I mean I know that's not
that much that you can do I move like g5
is just bad and yes super here stay with
the Bishop Bishop e7 also and they don't
think it makes a huge difference how
exactly you're going to stay with the
bishop cannot move your king here to e7
maybe but that's so every real time
management now is thinking forever well
you played many committal moves
immediately I'd really like to play this
out here not just win this on time ok
now is going for a move yeah well the
move Bishop d6 is not helping am I have
c7 then it's a important little point c7
buddy
okay and he's not going to get rid of
this pawn check black resins gym hmm I
still think this is Pedro actually or
isn't it isn't this a draw computer says
white wins I wasn't really sure but the
comp wants to play differently maybe her
computer just wants to walk the King up
hmm yeah computer sacem Winningham kind
of kind of surprised so this is this is
winning okay if I'm staying here like
here here yeah I mean I see the point
it's it's kind of difficult to prevent
that what if black um since using no I
cannot do that hmm i am not totally sold
here it said no way to hold that let's
say this kind of thing going here i am
threatening to go there let's seem like
a staying okay then i have d5 and I'm
connect idea will enter yeah so this was
the right way to go i wasn't sure really
yeah he just chat some and says that he
did not when when he gave up the porn he
wanted to play rook c8 rooks if I and he
overlooked the depending the pinning
thing a two diagonal a to f7 um but what
about the saying I'm still kind of if
I'm doing this kind of thing this is
what I what I want to actually dare ya
it's this winning or not this kind of
idea going up and up here and not king
of cells I has to do this this this this
kind of thing in staying
zoosk one that's a very nice one it's a
very nice oops wrong he cannot move the
King g5g five I will have a win the pawn
and the bishop cannot move as well he
can do that but then I'm just pushing up
that's a nice win so why do we win
anyway I wasn't I wasn't really I wasn't
seeing it that's clearly we should be
five is an immensely strong move nice
okay let's look through this a little
bit he played this this setup here which
it's not really that great the problem
is that those pieces don't do much okay
Queen to d7 i went to bishop here yeah k
nitey force was a move but going back as
it's okay went here yeah this was always
answered by bishop age six but this this
should be okay really takes tags and now
this rookie six move that was neat he
took take stakes and this and Bishop h6
is the point I have to play rook e1 the
command okay of course it's so simple
it's so simple what does this move now
it's so simple yeah now I'm having 25
anyway and he has to play I cannot go
here because this is probably winning
still bishop 86 tricky I can take d6
though which is very good and if you go
see I have the check check and again i
have here for the check
cap it was stronger Bishop age six was
kind of saving the day nor the comp
gifts g4 yeah I had this hunch but I
wasn't really sure then I decided to
play it safe with this and probably this
gives up most of the advantage okay 5v a
look Bishop f5 g-form takes takes takes
maybe I should go g5 now in with
hindsight I probably should have
attacking the knight and very quickly
going for Bishop reform and I it was
probably a better slide slide edge and
hear ya okay I went here I saw that I
saw this one this is the comp line but I
wasn't sure this line I did see a I was
sure that I'm better here because the
bishop is stronger than the night in
this position but I wasn't sure how much
it is so I wanted to I wanted to keep
keep the bishops and now he just he just
gave me the pawn no I think this was
decent play technically take cake yeah
okay Sofia King you one back kimi to jam
and now I should probably still avoid
this but it's possible that this is
really winning I wasn't I wasn't
completely sold on that but then nalysis
seems to show that white is winning and
I wasn't sure about that with the
reduced material here okay I was an
interesting game hope you enjoyed this
rapid game and well thanks for watching